what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to a brand
new cold Geass video I'm actually joined
today by my brother go then here he is
what out guys hope you say yeah and he
is the other half of anime uproar and
what I thought we do for this video is
we engage everybody and do the ultimate
Code Geass
wife Wars woo now we all know that Code
Geass is full of waifu options there are
so many to choose from
however me and goes and still end up
arguing all the time over call and
Kazuki we both claim Colin as our waifu
so what I thought I'd do to settle it
once and for all is I saw we take a Code
Geass rifle quiz and see which one of us
would actually get Colin Kazuki
unfortunately there is no good Code
Geass waifu quiz on the internet so what
i decided to do is to create one myself
now obviously i can't take the quiz
myself because i know the answers but i
am going to make goals and take it here
in this video and you guys can follow
along and take the quiz along with him
there are 11 questions in this quiz
seven different waifu options and the
link is right there in the description
if you want to follow along with us and
take the quiz yourself now goes and
promised me that he would be honest when
he's taking this quiz you won't try to
get colin on purpose he will be
answering questions based on what he is
actually like as a person isn't that
right golden how about Roger arrow you
are going to be honest in that Wiz but
okay alright I will be honest cuz he
will be honest and I will actually be
sitting here while he takes the quiz and
keep making sure that he is being honest
that he's not cheating anything like
that so yeah we will be taking the quiz
together feel free to join us and let us
know in the comments what your result
was hashtag waifu challenge alright guys
so here we go this is going to be our
set up golden is ready to take it out
I'm excited and I'm sitting here right
behind and making sure he's not doing
any funny business yeah I'm not gonna
cheat guys whatever now I'm going to be
calling you out if you're blatantly just
trying to get back there I'm going to
see so I'm going to call you out let's
do this guy's so should be fun and feel
free to follow along link in the
description all right here we go
I'm guessing it's not with
right it who is your favorite cool deal
or who is your Kobe avoid that joke one
on deaf ears
alright nice picture let's go what would
you like to do on a first date
stay in your wife who can cook for you
very tempting stay in and order takeout
that's nice to go for a romantic walk in
the city go shopping definitely not go
on a hunting trip no host a big party
together no plot and scheme alright so
if we're being honest here I'd say stay
in an order takeout which of these
character traits do you find the most
attractive kind and loving friendly and
outgoing honest and sincere quirky and
mysterious aggressive to everyone but
those who are closest to her passionate
about our beliefs and aggressive when
she has to be whatever that aggressive
on the outside but gentle on the inside
so if we're being honest kind of loving
most importantly we are being honest
like you sages well I think you think if
we're being honest like Wiz you're
supposed to be honest the other side
goes like you know I could play the
strategically but I'm playing it
honestly so what do you value the most
love loyalty friendship strength
companionship fairness justice
oh that's a hard one let's go with
I'd say just you are forced to choose
between love and your most cherished
beliefs what do you do you choose your
beliefs at all cost we choose love no
matter what you choose your beliefs at
first the loved ones out at the end love
is what you truly believe in beliefs
mean nothing as long as you are happy
the Leafs are for the weak hard power is
all that matters
hard power assignments like a military
power you know Malachi no nightmares you
don't know what to believe in anymore
um okay good question
you're forced to choose between one and
your most cherished beliefs so let's go
with the belief at all cost because I
think love will come as a result of that
anyways what do you fear the most
once we being alone being unpopular
being perceived as weak being perceived
as unjust being perceived as disloyal
being helpless not being with the person
you love let's go with being helpless I
just want to say completely unbiased Lee
but these are the best questions and
best cold vs quiz ever very funny I'll
just go say that yeah just anime uproar
like whoever made these quizzes is on
point
so picture Suzaku can't go wrong with
that you learn from a trusted source
that your best friend betrayed you how
do you react you destroy them
immediately
well you forgive them quickly
you are devastated friends are the most
important thing in the world
you are disappointed but you move on
there are more important things to worry
about you refuse to believe it your best
friend would never betray you
you accept it sometimes the trails the
only option you don't have friends
that's funny so a a few questions about
this no okay well since we don't know
how big the betrayal is I'll just say
you're disappointed but you move on
they're more important
forever which of these colors do like
the most I think those are gonna be
dealt okay red is not here which it
would be my color so we'll go with
purple a war suddenly breaks out in your
country what do you do you escape with
the person you love you lead an army to
annihilate your enemies I like that you
try to live your life as normally as
possible or you hide away and wait for
the right moment to strike you do
everything in your power to stop the
senseless bloodshed Suzaku
you follow orders and do what must be
done even if you don't like it
definitely not you feel that wars are of
little consequence in the overall scheme
of things I just wanna put in the Sousa
who is not an option for best waifu
textures a test shoot hmm a war
celebrates out in your country so it's
your country you have some kind of some
kind of a role to play I believe I don't
think it'd just abandon your people
different you're visiting so let's go
with you lead an army to annihilate your
enemies because they are unjust because
justice is born to me okay if your life
was in danger which of these would be
the best asset to have dedicated friends
to help you passion and skill an army
under your command
years of experience sincerity and the
ability to negotiate fair terms the
undying support of the person we love
the willingness to do whatever it takes
and survive I'm going to say dedicated
friends to help you because I feel like
they'll keep you motivated and do those
things as well so let's go is out which
of these pastimes do you enjoy the most
swimming cooking fighting being playful
and joking around spending time with
family lying around and being lazy I do
like that
hatching your next big plan yes we're
being honest yeah but just because I
like it doesn't mean I like it the most
so I'm going to say hatching your next
big plans because that's always the
thing I'd like to be doing most even
though I do like to do loser too
your birthday is coming up so eleventh
question I believe it's the last one
guys a lot of questions yeah oh man oh
man it better not be like rigged like
Nina no matter what and by the way he
doesn't know the answers the options
there are seven options I haven't told
them yet I'll tell you guys at the end
of the quiz what all the options are but
yeah go ahead and clean up our Sun stick
it looks like your birthday is coming up
how do you want to celebrate them throw
a huge birthday party celebrate with
family and close friends celebrate with
those most loyal two birthdays are
meaningless celebrate quietly at home
who has time for birthdays there are
more important things to do and it
doesn't matter how you celebrate it as
long as you're with the person you love
so I'm gonna say celebrate with family
and close friends oh man oh god those
got it oh my god I hope you guys see
over the ground over on why I think this
I settled it a lesson for all people I
think I could have hoped for a better
result
please read my description I wrote I
shall I shall
let's read it guys oh man whoo I told
you guys I told you from day one
cause mine okay your code geass wife was
calling Kazuki in public she puts on a
quiet and gentle persona but in reality
she is a passionate fighter for justice
and for Japan's independence from
imperial rule
she is arguably the most skilled
nightmare pilot in the world and she is
driven by a strong sense of justice and
a desire to avenge the death of her
brother at the hands of retaining an
aggressive tip don't call her out soon
did it where she will kick your ass and
then call you vodka
nice nice how they could be challenging
more he was there ensuring that I answer
modern wings oh wow what do you think
all right guys so you want to take if
you want to take this quiz um feel free
to check the link in the description the
options include I will reveal that right
now if you don't want to know you can
turn away now but the opposite cool call
and of course c2 of Cornelia Euphemia
Millie um and Valletta I think that's
all
and Shirley as well for that seven
that's seven right there take the quiz
let us know what you got as always think
of the quiz and if you want to keep
having the white boards discussion with
us come join us in the discord server
the link is the description is in the
description and of course if you like
this be sure to LIKE and subscribe it
love to have you here as part of this
community and it was it was awesome a
very fun I gotta say good job on the
quiz you guys will enjoy it there's no
real losers because I mean all those
girls are good white boos but yeah join
us for more waifu conversations into
this chord we have a whole page
dedicated to it and until next time he's
keeping his time he needs time I'll do
it until next time see you space cowboys
burn
[Music]
you
[Music]